Якщо ви втомилися від галасу й метушні великого міста
ласкаво просимо в Бутучани
Тут, між колись братською Росією
та Європейським Союзом - Румунією
живуть близько двох сотень людей
Більшість з них – літні люди та ті, хто їх доглядає
як наприклад, Іван Бабенко
Його родина живе тут не одне покоління,
як і майже всі в селі
Ми намагаємося з'ясувати
до кого мешканці Бутучан більш прихильні.
Адже це питання нині розкололо
політиків Молдови на два табори
Я вважаю, що людина має обирати сама,
куди і як хоче
А я отут, не туди і не в інший бік,
тому що у мене тут батьки
Ніхто нікуди не їде, ані в Росію, ані в Румунію
По обіді люди сходяться до мобільного кіоску
з яблуками та картоплею
На запитання "Як життя?" чуємо
"Погано, зовсім погано"
Невідомо, з ким жити,  щоб було краще.
Європа теж погано. Україна теж погано...
До єдиної крамниці в селі
з промовистою назвою "Магазин"
покупці заходять рідко
Не дивно, пояснює власник Давид Бабенко
Маючи в середньому 300 євро зарплатні на місяць
люди намагаються прогодуватися
з власного городу й саду
Усі намагаються заощаджувати
Нам потрібен сильний політик,
який нарешті виведе нас з кризи
Такий, яким ми зможемо пишатися
Щоб молодь не їхала звідси
Щоб тут знову вистачало роботи для всіх
Я за все життя і з росіянами працював, і з румунами
І так вам скажу: треба з усіма домовлятися
Уже майже десятиріччя при владі у Молдові проєвропейські сили
Утім, попри мільйонні субсидії від Заходу, економічна ситуація практично не поліпшилася
Багато хто розчарований відсутністю змін на краще
Відчути і побачити Європу,  як демонструє нам надвечір Іван Бабенко
у молдовському селі можна хіба що по телевізору
в благенькій батьківській хаті